se aproxima a una crisis alimentaria
mundial el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania quienes representan casi un
tercio del trigo y la cebada del planeta
ha disparado los precios de los
alimentos sumándose a una crisis
energética que impacta a los sistemas de
distribución
tal vez en polonia y bulgaria que gastan
una mayor parte de sus ingresos en
alimentos estarán mucho más afectados
por los precios más caros el sur de
europa áfrica egipto y los países árabes
también son grandes importadores de
cereales es posible que se enfrenten a
faltas de suministro y precios más altos
estos países realmente sufrirán el
mercado de alimentos ya venía en crisis
entre otras cosas por la pandemia de
kobe 19 además enfrenta la intensa
sequía que afecta a países como francia
eeuu canadá y la india este último tomó
la determinación de prohibir sus
exportaciones de trigo por sentir su
propia seguridad alimentaria amenazada
los ministros de agricultura del g7
rechazaron la decisión y la prohibición
afecta a países como bangladesh y nepal
que necesitan el trigo con urgencia los
jefes de estado y de gobierno del g7
deberán tomar una decisión concreta
sobre este tema y hacemos un llamado a
la india para que asuma sus
responsabilidades como miembro del g-20
pero la india no es la única nación que
está respondiendo a la crisis con
proteccionismo una veintena de países ha
colocado medidas restrictivas de
exportaciones ante esta situación el
temor es que millones de personas y
ciudades podrían ver a corto plazo
hambre desnutrición protestas flujos
migratorios y tensiones geopolíticas los
representantes del banco mundial el
fondo monetario internacional la
organización mundial de comercio y el
programa mundial de alimentos han
llamado a realizar acciones coordinadas
de suministro de alimentos de emergencia
soporte financiero y comercio abierto
para apoyar a las naciones más
vulnerables